Sony and Disney found their way back to
the bargaining table and the deal has
been struck all webhead will get at
least one more MCU set starring vehicle
one that we have a funny feeling we'll
have the word home somewhere in its
title these are just a few things you
can expect details about spider-man's
third solo outing in the MCU are
exceedingly slim surprisingly though we
already know the film's release dates as
it was announced the same time that
Marvel and Sony went public with the
renewing of their shared custody deal
spider-man's next web slinging adventure
will hit the big screen on July 16th
2021 at least us where it slotted at the
moment it's possible it could be pushed
off to a later date
for a couple of reasons first marvel's
2021 slate is already pretty crowded
previously announced to be on sub for
that year a shang-chi and The Legend of
the ten rings on February 12th Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness on
May 7th and Thor love and thunder on
November 5th if Spidey threes early
state holds up it would mark the first
time Marvel has released for MCU
pictures in the same year which even the
most hardcore fans might see as crowding
the market and that's before we even get
to that year's Disney Plus output also
that summer we'll see the release of
another highly anticipated superhero
film Matt Reeves the Batman which hits
screens on June 25th the Robert
Pattinson starring flick will be the
first Batman solo film in nearly a
decade while Marvel has every reason to
be confident in the web-slinger's
ability to kill it at the box office
there would be no shame in rethinking
putting him up against the Dark Knight
no no no no no no that's definitely no
that's definitely out we want to watch
it plot details for the 3rd MCU
spider-man flick have not been divulged
in all likelihood because the movie is
still tangled up in early developments
we do know one thing however life is
about to get even more difficult for
Peter Parker spider-man far from home
ended on a heck of a cliffhanger with
Parker's identity haven't been revealed
to the public
thanks to Mysterio and Jay jonah Jameson
in the MCU with Jameson is apparently a
conspiracy theorist vlogger and not a
newspaper man but he still looks a heck
of a lot like JK Simmons there's a real
blockbuster race yourselves you might
want to sit out
spider-man's maybe is Peter Parker of
course we can speculate outside of the
third Tom Hollands movie Sony is
continuing to develop at Spidey related
properties independently of involvement
from Marvel Studios at the moment to
those projects include venom to Morbius
and Kraven the hunter which recently
found a screenwriter in the equalizer
series scribe Richard Wenk it should be
noted that since the days of the aborted
Andrew Garfield starring a magazine
spider-man franchise Sony has been keen
to get the sinister six a revolving team
of old web heads greatest nemec's onto
the screen first
[Music]
with all of the spider Wheeling's and
dealings that have gone on in recent
months fans could be forgiven for being
a bit confused as to the nature of Sony
and Marvel's relationship at this point
follow us here venom which starred Tom
Hardy and featured exactly no references
to spider-man surprised everyone by
grossing over eight hundred and fifty
million dollars worldwide
despite lukewarm reviews Morbius a solo
vehicle for the living vampire and
longtime Spidey nemesis which Sony has
on tap for 2020 may very well follow
suits both films are part of the thus
fast body less sony universe of marvel
characters everyone knows that the MCU
reigns supreme so why not engineer a
crossover between the two universes in
fact this may very well be what's
happening and if so spider-man 3 will
likely be a focal point of the strategy
no less an authority that Marvel Studios
had honcho Kevin Feige has teased that
Spidey is quote the only hero with the
super power to cross cinematic universes
and in the past
he suggested that Hardy's venom and
Holland Spidey could one day meet on the
big screen it's all but certain that the
two studios are busy hashing out the
details even as you're watching this but
for now we'll just have to wait and see
how it all plays out what if spider-man
far from homes biggest twist came during
the Flex post-credit scene when it was
revealed that the Nick Fury in Maria
hill would seem for the entirety of the
film were in fact Skrull imposters
assigned to Parker but a Vale Fury who
was busy well in space tending to some
secret mission or another on a ship full
of Scrolls all of this while being
extremely shoeless jokes aside this sets
up a massive wave of speculation that
the flick had been tasked with doing a
bit of heavy lifting in setting up an
MCU adaptation of The Secret Invasion
storyline in which Scrolls infiltrate
the highest ranks of power on earth by
way of you know imitating everyone
remarks made by director John watts
seemed to indicate though that the twist
was actually his decision and not a
mandate from on high this would likely
mean that Fury's space Jones isn't in
fact setting up major future
developments for the MCU as a whole so
could its have been teasing a continued
role for fury and all the scrolls
next spider-man movie for now is
completely unknown but our money is on
the superspy returning to earth to
assume its stewardship of Parker with a
few interesting stories to tell when
solely in marble mater but the first
question on fans Minds was the obvious
one for how long all we know for certain
is that aside from a third solo venture
Spidey will appear in at least one more
Marvel Studios film beyond that the
future is a question mark considering
that the MCU and Sony's universe of
Marvel characters are finally making
overtures toward recognizing each
other's existence though there are a few
ways is likely to go estudios could at
previously-mentioned find a viable
narrative for the character to switch
cinematic universes or as dead liners
suggest they could form a loose
connection with a kind of callin
response aesthetic which would keep the
franchise's largely separates but
tangentially connected or if the two
Studios can truly see their way clear to
giving the fans what they want the two
universes could merge with Sony's
established characters being absorbed
into the MCU it seems like a pretty
slight possibility and it might be but
it also appears to be the option likely
to generate the maximum amount of
box-office dollars so we're going to go
ahead and call it not impossible
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]